what's going on people today we're about
to break down episode 26 of attack on
time season 4 in which an all-out war
breaks out between the scouts and the
agres in this video i'll be explaining
everything that i thought was
interesting including the return of the
female titan magast change of heart and
how far connie was willing to go to save
the world before we get into it though i
do these reviews every week so i'd
appreciate if you hit that sub button
and as usual drop a like if you liked
the video
also if you stick around till the very
end then you'll see an exclusive preview
from my upcoming video about the
ultimate reality where ervin got the
colossal titan
okay so in the last episode the alliance
were discussing how they planned to stop
the rumbling and one of the things they
agreed was that they needed to get
access to this flying boat earlier in
the season kyomi was the one who brought
this special plane to the island and
right now it's the only thing that might
be fast enough to reach aaron in time
the problem however is that when they
finally made it to the port the yaegris
were already there and had locked the
place down with flock holding kyomi as
his personal hostage
episode 26 begins through the lens of a
telescope as mcgath and hanji observed
the situation from a distance the
general notices that the flying boat is
still in one piece which is surprising
because if the aegis were to destroy it
then it would end any chance of the
rumbling being stopped
regardless there were a few plausible
explanations as to why they hadn't done
it yet with the first being that at this
point flock didn't know for certain this
alliance to stop the rumbling was a
thing technology like this would take
decades for the island to recreate
meaning that it's smarter to keep the
flying boat intact until they have a
good reason not to of course if reiner
and the gang were to attack then that
would be a valid justification for the
jagers to tear it down putting the
alliance in a very delicate situation if
they make a wrong move then their one
method of reaching aaron will disappear
so whatever strategy they choose it
basically needs to be perfect when it
comes to annie her suggestion was to
quickly massacre the enemy in one go by
using the combined power of their titan
shifters and other weapons
if successful it would mean that the
jagrus would be wiped out before they
have a chance to destroy the ship but
this plan caused the scouts to hesitate
for obvious reasons
many of the people defending the poor
are friends they've known since all the
way back in their cadets and connie
especially didn't seem comfortable with
killing them on top of that mikasa
highlights that an all-out attack would
also lead to the azmobito getting hurt
which is something that can't be allowed
to happen besides the fact that they're
her distant relatives the azimibito need
to be kept safe because they're the only
ones who can prepare the flying boats
onyankpon goes on to explain that
although he has the skills to pilot the
plane his ruse engineers are the ones
with the knowledge on how to prepare it
for flight and without them it won't be
able to get in the air
therefore the alliance had to think of a
plan that would prevent the boat from
getting destroyed while giving the
engineers time to set it up while also
hordes of viegras might be trying to
kill them by itself that mission would
be difficult enough but the fact that
scouts want to do it without causing
deaths makes it virtually impossible
annie then throws some shader arm in by
asking him to tell her his grand plan
just like he did 4 years ago when he
lured her into a trap
on that occasion he told her a
completely fake plan in the hopes that
she'd follow him underground however in
the present day he doesn't seem too
proud about what he did and in my
opinion it's because seeing berto's
memories and you know seeing things from
the warriors perspective it's made him
empathize with what they had to go
through
anyway soon after this connie has an
outburst as he's still not on board with
the prospect of killing his fellow
islanders which causes annie to come to
a realization although the warriors
might have an obligation to save their
homelands from being trampled the scouts
never had this burden and they shouldn't
be forced to murder their own people if
they don't want to she goes on to say
that if these four have been in the same
position as the warriors then they
wouldn't have attacked the walls and
started this whole war between marley
and paradise
these words caused reiner to recall what
eren said to him back in liberio and
i'll explain why he thinks of that in
this moment
if we flash back to the whole scene
reiner had just admitted that annie and
berto wanted to end the mission but he's
the one who convinced them to keep going
and attack war maria in aaron's mind
this confirmed to him that he and rhino
were the same since they each pushed
forward to wipe out their enemies even
when the people around them were against
it
in both situations they dragged their
comrades along to help put an end to
countless lives and in the present day
reiner makes the decision that he
doesn't want to drag any more people
into this conflict he tells connie and
the rest of them that they don't need to
interfere with this upcoming battle and
urges them to stay behind and watch the
fighting from a distance
now moving on earlier in the episode
hanji noticed something about the
rumbling that made her stand up and take
a look what's happening here is that the
war titans have entered the water and
are now swimming to mali and because
they're so hot the water begins to emit
steam the steam gives a clear indication
of how fast the titans are moving and
based on this hanji estimates that some
of the titans have already arrived on
the continent
this means that towns and cities to the
northeast of mali have almost certainly
been trampled and the news causes mcgath
to take immediate action
pushing on yankopono out the way he
shoves the other net against the rock
and stomps her arm into a different
dimension the general covers her mouth
so that her scream doesn't draw any
attention and the reason he's torturing
her is so that she'll tell him where the
founding titan is
even though her will to live was pretty
low before this the way things have
progressed have made her interested to
see how this all plays out and in the
end she basically says that she'll tell
them his location if they bring her
along
following that macathan looks up at
gabby and has a clear look of regret on
his face similar to what happened the
night before
back then he went to reach out to her
because he felt guilty about the fact
that marley's brainwashing had robbed
her of a normal childhood and this is
the case not just for gabby but for
rainer and the other warriors as well as
the head of the unit mcgath played a
significant role in making this happen
and here he apologizes for the things he
said around the campfire the argument he
had with jon was simply him trying to
justify his own actions because deep
down he knew that both himself and
marley were awful for the things they've
done
last night he was too afraid to accept
that which is why he put his hand down
but after seeing the things he's seen
his perspective on aldians in the world
has now evolved that being said the
general does still want to stop aaron
not only to save mali but also so that
future generations can learn about their
mistakes it's interesting that when he
talks about future generations learning
their history the anime pans to show us
yellen his expression as her motivation
for helping zeke and lying about her
heritage was so that she could be part
of a legend that future generations
would hear about
meanwhile down by the harbour flock was
seemingly having the happiest day of his
life as he observed the wall titans
rapidly pacing towards the globe
he explains to kyomi that his rule will
be trampled just like all the other
nations which i thought was a bit harsh
considering that they were the one
country who were actually willing to
work with paradise if anyone was going
to be spared it would have been them but
this line is basically a confirmation
that aaron really is taking no prisoners
anyhow in this scene we can see that
kyomi wasn't his only hostage as there
was a room full of terrified engineers
at least three of whom had been killed
already flock previously mentioned that
one of his main jobs is to wipe out any
resentment left on the island and so
he's taking the same approach with his
uru as he did with the volunteers that
approach is that anyone who doesn't do
what they're told or tries to resist is
executed while everyone else will be
allowed to live if they're willing to
contribute to elder going forward
as he continues to ramble kyomi then
interrupts him and tells flock that the
violence won't end even once owners
wiped out the rest of humanity we know
for a fact that what she's saying is
true because even before mali first
attacked there was still a ton of
bloodshed on the island whether it was
state-sponsored executions serial
killers on the loose or political
assassinations gyomi's opinion is that
it's pretty much human nature for these
things to continue like they always have
and he even accepts that she does have a
point he goes on to say however that
what's important now is for people to
know their place in the world and that
was a thinly veiled warning to everyone
in the room
essentially he's acknowledging that
their society on parodies is more
primitive compared to the rest of the
world and that while it would be nice to
have hizrus tech it's not essential for
their survival in that way he's telling
kiyomi that he's not afraid to kill them
and that the azimobito clan need to do
what they're told if they want to live
despite all of their technological
advancements in the new world the eren
is creating their place is now below the
aegirus and this is what he's trying to
make her realize
suddenly out of nowhere connie and armin
interrupt this conversation as they ride
into the harbor on horseback and this
was the beginning of their plan to get
to the flying boat without killing
anyone phase one of this plan involves
convincing jaegers that they're all
still on the same side and to do that he
claims that they've been chasing after
the warriors this whole time and now the
armored and cart tyson have escaped by
sea the implication here is that flock
needs to let them use the flying boat so
that they can continue chasing after the
enemy and for that reason they also need
to let the azmobito prepare the flight
he and connie then rush towards the
plane while telling flock to release the
mechanics and as they get closer we see
it's being guarded by daz and samuel
these four have all known each other
since they first joined the cadets and
daz in particular is memorable for being
the most anxious and possibly the most
useless of the entire group
regardless of that he and samuel are now
both proud jaegerys who are fully in
support of aaron's plan to rumble all
life beyond the walls it was them who
rigged this flying boat with explosives
in case he needed to be destroyed
causing armor and connie to hysterically
ask them to disconnect it
in this scene you can tell that samuel
is hesitant to do that since there are
suspicions among the aegiris that these
two are working with mali flock first
began to suspect this when mikasa and
the rest of them went missing but after
a brief back and forth dad is eventually
convinced to disconnect the detonator
with the explosives now being inactive
the two of them have an almost terrified
look on their face and that's because
during this whole interaction they were
nervous that their plan wouldn't work
inside the building though flock's
suspicion continued to grow as he began
to poke holes in armin's story when the
two scouts arrived they claimed that the
warriors were heading south so logically
if armin knew that then it would have
made more sense to pursue them by train
rather than on horses the events of the
last episode demonstrated just how much
more effective that would have been and
there's also the fact that the scouts
were sneaking around without asking any
of the aegis for help
even though he had no evidence that
they'd been betrayed his inescapable gut
feeling was that something was wrong so
to deal with this he decides to execute
more of the remaining mechanics
a second meaning we can draw from this
moment is that in flock's mind even if
armin's story is true he doesn't think
the warriors have a chance of stopping
aaron by themselves anyway as he goes to
kill one of the engineers ambassador
kiyomi leaps out of her chair and the
scene pans out to a point where we just
hear three gunshots the sound of these
shots lets everyone in the port know
that something isn't right and in the
room flock is getting whooped by a
middle-aged woman some more jaegers then
burst in after hearing the gunshots but
before they can kill kyomi mikasa
crashes through the window and deals
with both of them we know that flock
already had his own suspicions about her
so after seeing this betrayal he
clumsily uses his gear to break out and
lets his soldiers know the situation
this leads to an instant reaction with
many of the aegis swooping in to blow up
the room and mikasa only barely makes it
out as the explosion throws her into a
wall
on the stairs the azimutha were then
confronted by more soldiers but these
ones were killed by hanji and magath
who's now ditched his malian uniform in
favor of the survey called jacket their
mission right now is to get everyone
into the basement so that reiner and
annie can go wild with their titans
without needing to worry about
collateral damage before we get into
that though down by the flying boat a
panic dazz goes to reconnect the
explosives as armin tries to step in
samuel then brutally shoots him in the
drawer chest and stomach but part of the
reason he did this was because armin has
shifter abilities his colossal titan
means that he's able to survive injuries
like this which is why he ended up
getting shot while connie managed to
avoid the same treatment having realized
that they've been betrayed samuel is
seriously hurt by this and starts to cry
as he reminisces about this memory back
in season 1. back then sasha had stolen
some meat from one of their superior
offices but her reasoning was that once
they capture more land from the titans
there'll be even more meat to go around
following that samuel and connie agreed
with this and they were the first ones
to ask for some of the michi stole and
you can tell that since then samuel
never imagined that they'd be in a
scenario like this
switching back to the azmobito they were
hiding at the bottom of this staircase
as the aegiris continued to bombard the
entrance with thunderspears them being
underground gave reiner and annie the
freedom they needed to go wild and this
sequence of her using the odm gear was
by far one of the best cuts of the
episode the fact she hadn't practiced
for four years made this even more
impressive than it already was and the
warriors pull up behind flock to
manifest their titans
next to the flying boat this titan
lightning catches samuel by surprise and
while he's distracted connie uses it as
a chance to tackle him meanwhile over by
the rocks the rest of the alliance was
observing with the captain having woken
up just in time to watch the show
the female and armored titans then
manifest soon after this and the jaegris
rampage that annie had been asking for
finally gets underway
when it comes to connie he and samuel
were fighting over possession of the gun
while daz continued to reconnect the
explosives zombie armin then muscles up
the strength to lunge at him cause like
we've established under no circumstances
can the alliance allow the ship to be
destroyed
eventually they get into a situation
where daz has a gun to his head but when
you take into account his personality in
my opinion there was a pretty low chance
that he was ever gonna pull the trigger
that being said a low chance doesn't
mean it's impossible and an injury to
the brain like this could be fatal even
for him obviously we've seen that rhino
has survived worse but in those
situations he was able to transfer his
consciousness which isn't something the
army is known to be aware of i think
it's fair to say that in this moment
armin was leaving his fate in daz's
hands and over to the side samuel tries
to understand why this is happening from
his perspective this whole betrayal must
be super confusing because they've been
fighting for the same goal their whole
lives and now all of a sudden connie and
army are switching sides to save people
that hate them this is when armin
flashes back to something bertolt said
when he betrayed them which is that
someone has to be the person to stain
their hands with blood in berto's case
he hated himself for having to kill
people but he did what he had to do
because he didn't really have another
choice
similarly armin and kony are now in
pretty much the exact same situation
because they didn't want to kill anyone
and they made that pretty clear but now
they've been forced into a corner where
they have to choose between daz and
samuel's life or the lives of millions
of innocent people ultimately connie
chooses the latter and this scene was
done incredibly well because he shoots
daz and then slowly realizes what he has
to do next in the manga version it
seemed like he just killed daz and then
instantly shot samuel but the anime does
it way better because you can really see
how conflicted he was in this moment
the episode ends with the haunting shot
of connie screaming over his friend's
dead body proving just how far he's
willing to go to stop the rumbling
anyway people that was my breakdown for
episode 26 of attack on titan season 4
and if it helped your understanding of
the episode in any way then be sure to
hit that sub button for more videos like
this
finally as a quick thank you for those
of you who stuck around to the end i've
been working on my newest installment of
what if erin got the colossal titan the
new video will pick up immediately after
the last part left off with the
warhammer titan confronting the scouts
in liberio from there it spirals into an
all-out war that covers literally the
entire malian continent and one of my
intentions was to show how everyone
would see the weaknesses in mali that
could have been exploited in the process
there will be characters on both sides
we have to make hard decisions and the
second half of the video will be all
about how the world reacts to these
events
all the artwork and the script is now
fully complete and it's a pretty long
script so um i'm hoping to record it all
next week and maybe get the video out by
wednesday or thursday but if i can't get
out on those days then it will be coming
out probably the monday or tuesday of
the following week
if you've watched this far then i'm
assuming you're a fan of the series so i
would say that you should turn on your
notifications so you don't miss it
because you know this is in my opinion
my best ever video so i'm trying to make
it perfect i want everything to be you
know i want the editing to be good as
well so um yeah when it comes out be
sure to have notifications on so you
don't miss it
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out